hola a todos bienvenidos al programa a
canadá en las américas café de este 8
viernes 8 de junio de 2018
es un placer entonces que estén todos
ustedes con nosotros nosotros con
ustedes en el programa leonardo jiménez
gimeno pablo gómez barrios rufo valència
y quien les habla leonora chapman les
damos entonces todos la bienvenida están
viendo este programa en directo en
facebook en youtube y pues para los que
no puedan estar hoy con nosotros el fin
de semana el programa está en nuestro
sitio eres en este punto o sea cómo
están ustedes hay varias esta semana es
muy política en canadá eminentemente
política tenemos el g7 el grupo de los
siete que hay navegar acaba de llegar
trump y los otros grupos que se están
llevando a quien charló ua en quebec en
canadá el grupo de los siete eso a nivel
internacional a nivel nacional
propiamente hablando de canadá ontario
tuvo elecciones ayer y los conservadores
pues volvieron al poder después de unos
15 años
más o menos interesantes quien está en
la cabeza del partido de nador no
exactamente una familia muy política de
ontario
exactamente ahora hablando del g7 a como
dijo fijo el ruso ya llegaron la
instancia llegaron todos los líderes de
europa y de américa del norte
me preguntaba al ver las declaraciones
de trump y de la unión europea si se
está tal vez dibujando un nuevo orden
mundial económico rufo si escuchamos a
hablar a donald trump las amenazas que
está alargando contra la unión europea
contra canadá y de manera cada vez más
violenta verbalmente hablando podríamos
decir también está protestando y dice
que la unión europea se está haciendo
rica con el aprovechándose del mercado
estadounidense dice que no tiene ningún
problema en terminar con el tlcan más
bien si quiere terminar con el tlcan y
empezar discusiones bilaterales en fin
propone que rusia vuelva a la mesa del
g7 que sea un g8 como antes estuvo en
durante exactamente y que fue con él
después una decisión que se rusia se fue
se la sacó por lo de crimea creo que era
por eso en fin hay toda una serie de
cosas que este presidente estadounidense
está moviendo en el planeta y tal vez
por eso creo que se puede hablar de un
nuevo
en que se está dibujando rufo es una
fractura muchos analistas coinciden en
que este eje 7 que justamente antes fue
eje 8 y que hoy es que seis más uno sí
claro que sí más uno y justamente macon
dijo justamente que podríamos primero
dijo el que no hay líderes que duren
para siempre
y segundo que pues en estos países
pueden seguir adelante con su propio
grupo el g6 y por otro lado alemania que
había indicado inclusive que alemania
algunos diputados alemanes de 100 que
alemania no debería participar
justamente porque había que acabar con
esta farsa de la amistad transatlántica
porque lo que estaba haciendo eeuu no
era no era javi ponían pueden poner
riesgo básicamente una alianza que duró
más de 43 años
sí pero mccrone tiene un discurso es el
que tiene el discurso más fuerte contra
trump pero alemania cuidadito con
alemania porque va a suavizar la cosa
alemania porque gran parte de sus
exportaciones van a eeuu sobre todo si
tocamos el tema del automóviles lo decía
un periodista
y estamos muy bien todos quieren
oponerse a trump quien empieza el vacío
india justamente dijo que cuando el
indio decide comprar el sistemas de
misiles antiaéreos de rusia viene la
amenaza de eeuu en ya dice no diga lo
que diga eeuu nosotros tener una
relación histórica con rusia turquía
también dice lo mismo le dice que amen a
estados unidos amenaza con no de
venderles el f-35
y turquía y además comprar un mix ahora
qué triste es andar comprando misiles
habla claro claro hablando de venta y
compra de armas entonces no son
compatibles con sistemas de la otan
etcétera entonces hay países que
phillips dando la espalda a eeuu ya de
hecho bueno hoy en día también dijo que
no iba a respetar las sanciones de eeuu
contra irán y contra venezuela eso lo
dijo ya la semana pasada regresando al
g7
el problema según los analistas es que
europa no está unida justamente tú
hablabas de además ya entonces
las posiciones no están unidas y se
mantuviera unida breman la unión
verdaderamente digo la unión europea ahí
si se le podría hacer contrapeso a eeuu
pero finalmente lo que ha hecho trump es
dividir a divide y reinarás decían por
ahí entonces eso es lo que él ha hecho y
eso es lo que hace que en este eje 6 ie6
1 bloque europeo
tenga no tenga el peso que debería tener
lo que le da mucha la actitud a trump de
poderse permitir de llegar cuando le da
la gana y vivirse cuando le da la gana
porque se va a ir mañana temprano y
digamos que todo esto es este este
conflicto que está creando trump también
se inició cuando impuso estos aranceles
a las importaciones del acero y también
el aluminio y de la luz
y en contra partido lo cual pues
destruido salió justamente en cierta
medida a atacarlo también a trump como
diciendo ya como que perdió un poco la
paciencia de jugar el el bueno de la
historia no entonces crudo también se
está enfrentando en este momento a las
políticas de eeuu habrá que ver qué pasa
en esta cumbre es ya trump dijo que
mañana se va a tempranísimo no se queda
para discutir la cuestión de por ejemplo
de las políticas medioambientales se va
justo antes no entonces está viendo un
poco el perfil de este presidente fíjate
uno de los fíjense digo uno de los temas
centrales en discusión son el nuevo
mundo laboral eso es lo que van a
discutir por supuesto que se está
hablando de nuevas tecnologías cuando se
hablan de nuevos trabajos y cómo se
puede insertar en esto tronco cuando
está hablando de que ya hay que ir a
buscar a la nueva generación de
trabajadores del carbón por ejemplo que
para él esto es una perdedera de tiempo
el g7 lo vienen a distraer
y algo muy importante que él tiene en la
mente y que son las negociaciones con
corea del norte que la reunión con ccoo
con kim jong un quien la semana próxima
ahora mañana se va entonces a singapur
donde va a ser que piense que esto es
una distracción y por eso es que se va
por eso es que le tiene muy poco respeto
digamos a esta reunión que se está
llevando a cabo aquí en que ver que sin
embargo está presente es decir ya cuando
recordemos cuando fue la cumbre de las
américas que tampoco asistió mandó a un
lugarteniente a uno de sus segundos él
es exactamente sin embargo a esta
reunión de que venga el g7 está presente
quiere decir que tiene algo que decir
algo que defender lo que tiene que decir
es como éste como este vendedor de
alfombras aquí lo colocan como director
de orquesta y tiene que pagar salarios y
escuchar a una la 'novena sinfonía' y
escucha que la percusión son solamente
dos veces
y entonces por qué tienes que pagar el
percusionista si solamente tocan dos
veces y lo que está en crisis es el
modelo de dominación imperial porque eso
es clientelista porque como él no tiene
experiencia en relaciones
internacionales
pero desde otro punto de vista
no no la no la tiene porque no tiene por
lo siguiente porque comprendería por
ejemplo que ese estado clientelista este
estado de crear estados clientes porque
eso que son sirven a partir de fines
financiamientos contratos inversiones
etcétera no por eso yo digo que lo tiene
pueblo tiene desde el punto de vista
financiero desde sus empresas privadas
que sus empresas están en todo el
entorno excelentemente bien el problema
con él es confundir a dirigir un país
con dirigir una empresa yo creo que ahí
está la cosa y no es el único en el
mundo y lo que christie's está pues
justamente lo que le está cortando
costos básicamente quería reducir por
ejemplo todas las misiones militares
estadounidenses
quería salir de irak son sus generales
que convencieron de lo contrario cuando
estaría mal rufo que salga de irak no
pues le haría mucho bien al mundo
imaginemos venezuela-colombia instalar
una base militar en eeuu les dejarían no
sé aunque colombia acaba el presidente
de colombia acaba de meter el colombia
es el primero y único país
latinoamericano que forma parte de la
otan a este presidente colombiano se le
dio el premio nobel de la paz y una vez
que se le entregó el premio nobel de la
paz lo primero que hace que se da vuelta
y meta colombia en la otan que es una
organización guerrera le dio el premio
nobel de la paz a obama que fue en su
presidencia donde en el mundo a partir
de la milicia estadounidense o sea un
premio político más que trabajar vamos a
ver entonces qué pasa esto recién
empieza por ahora es todo protocolar en
quebec van a almorzar juntos en fin la
verdadera discusión va a ser si es que
existe va a ser esta tarde y mañana a la
mañana y habría que ver qué es lo que
nuestros oyentes nuestros nuestro
público piensa respecto
[Música]
exactamente ruego gracias por recordarlo
y si nos gustaría también que ustedes
nos digan cómo ven desde sus países esta
reunión del g7 que se está llevando aquí
a cabo en canadá y también hablemos
ahora dijimos al principio de política a
nivel nacional y justamente leonardo
estuviste mencionando a la familia ford
ford el candidato conservador en ontario
que es la provincia más populosa de
canadá y más endeudadas
y se llevó a cabo elecciones ayer y
terminó con el reinado de 15 años del
partido liberal y ganó las elecciones
hay que recordar no sé si la gente
nuestros oyentes se acuerdan de hermanos
y justamente vos querías hablar
para confundirse la ventaja así que fue
un personaje bastante llamativo de la
política no hay por su política no
política justamente quizás un sesgo
medio
digamos sin tener todo el poderío
económico que tiene el presente eeuu
pero tiene tiene esa el primer ministro
de la provincia de la provincia dice si
vice es que no es xenófobo para nada es
actuar al contrario trabaja muchísimo
con las comunidades sin embargo la
campaña no hablo una palabra de
inmigración y no hablo una palabra de
cuestiones que tienen que ver con la
inmigración en sí pero pero pero se sabe
que él trabaja con la inmigración
entonces no fue preocupado es que no fue
pues es cierto lo preocupante digo yo y
ahí está la pregunta cómo fue que lo
eligieron es que presentó una en su
plataforma habló de muchísimas medidas
económicas que va a tomar si es elegido
pero nunca dijo de qué presupuesto
disponía ni de dónde iba a salir el
dinero bueno el problema si lo votaron
es que el problema serio es que ontario
está en deuda es la provincia canadiense
más endeudada en este momento
y realmente es difícil creo que tiene
que ver con hidro hidro
6 millones de dólares el año pasado ganó
como salario ahora ese tema cuando vos
lo decís a la gente pega fuerte porque
entre un trabajador que gana 30 mil 40
mil dólares anuales y un director de una
empresa del estado que gane 6 millones
hay un problema también solo para poner
en contexto ford ganó obtuvo el 40 por
ciento de los votos es decir tuvo 76
diputados y el nuevo partido democrático
que creo también que es el gran ganador
también de estas elecciones obtuvo 40
diputados que es una elección histórica
y ya te diga te doy pablo la palabra y
el partido de liberal de ontario tuvo
sólo siete diputados más ni siquiera
como partido
por lo menos exacto pero es interesante
resaltar acá leonora que sólo 50 por
ciento de los electores se presentaron
votar a las urnas
esta es la democracia
50 por ciento un 40 por ciento voto por
favor exacto así que lo ganaron pero
para dentro y bueno vamos a ver yo creo
que aquí se está dibujando también otro
canadá no es decir a ello hay una fuerza
tal vez que se está extendiendo y que es
la derecha canadiense conservadores está
de nuevo surgiendo en el ámbito político
canadiense se escucha cada vez más al ex
primer ministro harper que está también
se acaba de publicar un libro es muy
activo con los grupos republicanos sobre
todo en eeuu fuera de la esfera pública
ahora bien silencioso después de que de
haber perdido las elecciones están
volviendo lentamente entonces hay
también algo que se está dibujando en
canadá habrá que puedes observar lo que
está lo que se viene en los próximos
años rufo no sé si quieres agregar algo
sobre los de forma es decir como ves vos
el hecho de que por ejemplo no haya
presentado en su plataforma un
algo concreto sobre por ejemplo el
presupuesto que él piensa manejar o hizo
muchísimas promesas y cómo es que la
gente lo eligió porque mi pregunta es
por qué la gente se cansó del partido
liberal qué es lo que hizo malo como
dijo pablo en una conversación son 15
años y hay un desgaste también no hay
una fórmula muy interesante en la
política en canadá hay unos países
occidentales y es esto del cambio por el
cambio porque es el primero que hay por
ejemplo hay documentación y hay vídeos
grabados por ejemplo en el que ford
indica ordena señala a sus miembros de
partido que todo lo que tienen que hacer
es simplemente hacer firmar tarjetas en
blanco que ellos se van a encargar de
poner los nombres eso es fraude eso es
fraude porque fue ese envase ese es el
número de miembros que se elige al líder
del partido conservador y lo que era lo
que él la prueba concreta es que él
el falsificó el digamos que manipuló el
sistema de tal modo que los miembros
tienen que pagar 10 dólares y lo que él
dijo es que solamente firman yo voy a
pagar o vamos a pagar nosotros los 10
dólares es decir esa búsqueda de
miembros o falsos miembros o miembros
que no han cumplido con las normas eso
está documentado es un candidato que se
presenta sin justamente sin un plan
económico claro es eso es preocupante
sin un plan económico esta cuestión
central de todo el esta familia fue de
ontario tienen el rasgo de ser populares
digamos de acercarse de tener esta
afinidad con la población que no que no
está cerca cercana a los a los ciclos de
poder político económico o cultural 6 y
lo que es interesante es que su fuerza
estaba en toronto y toronto se extendió
salió de acción pero digamos espero que
el fuerte de su votación estuvo en
toronto pero anoche no pero estuvo en
las afueras de toronto sí pero
lo que quiero decir es que en toronto lo
que se vio ya con los liberales por
ejemplo fue cuando los liberales
propusieron planes de reforma del
sistema educativo en los que se iba a
ampliar la visión de la sexualidad
educación para los niños más temprano
eso hizo saltar a las comunidades
culturales de comillas que tienden a ser
más conservadoras que las canadienses
esto en general y esto lo saben los
conservadores jason kenny es juanma
stern manipular ese aspecto en un ex
ministro ex ministro de stephen harper
entonces s ahí está una parte de su
apoyo en una zona en la capital
multicultural del país o toronto ontario
con 14 millones de habitantes 4 de cada
10 canadienses
aún viven en ontario sano bueno entonces
cuando es cuando asume después
seguramente me olvidé de verificar eso
de todas maneras pues fue elegido porque
no lo espera mucho no existen vengan
inmediatamente bueno entonces es otra
otra línea que habrá que seguir análisis
y también repercusiones en el resto de
canadá esto de los consumidores
observadores al gobierno federal si
también exactamente bueno entonces bien
movida la cosa aquí en canadá no será
así es bueno vamos entonces ahora
tenemos correos de nuestros oyentes que
se están acumulando y acumulando vamos
entonces a empezar si leonardo yo antes
decirle feliz y del periodista argentino
si verdad porque argentina brujos de
river nosotros somos argentina así que
feliz del periodista gente que viene a
trabajar acá
seis días haber jugado varios partidos y
podremos en realidad comentar a algunos
mientras está de fondo
podríamos hacer después de una más como
hacíamos un juego una vez entre nosotros
a ver quién llega por lo menos a ocho si
los ocho partidos ocho países bueno
entonces vamos con los mensajes leonardo
así es tengo un mensaje que está escrito
por jim le clara dice buenos días estoy
aprendiendo español y lee el texto el
verano se anuncia caluroso en canadá
aprendí sobre el pronóstico de verano y
mejorado mis habilidades en el idioma
español
muchas gracias su información en español
es todo el tiempo muy valiosa gracias a
ustedes mi estudio se mejora es gil le
clara que nos escribía muy bien bueno no
sé si de montreal
tenemos tenemos escucha veedores que nos
están escuchando viendo en este momento
césar palacios y está ahí
en abril desde dice hola desde ese día
cerca de cappelle donde vive mi madre
entonces pues ella pues cuenta un poco
que su madre estuvo hospitalizada pero
que ya salió y sería mejorando y dice
echo de menos escuchados en directo un
abrazo a todos
sofía barrios mi sobrina dice un saludo
desde barranquilla colombia nelsy
remiendo vida desde brasil dice
y gilberto martínez dice saludo desde
nicaragua a pues muchísimas gran
nicaragua muy bien muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros seguimos con los
mensajes busy aquí tenemos un mensaje a
propósito del tema de la población de
que nada envejece y las personas mayores
ahora superan a los niños
marín garcía solís escribe indicando
buenos días somos su matrimonio jubilado
de costa rica y nos gustaría compartir y
establecer intercambios o prestar
colaboración con grupos de jubilados en
toronto montreal quebec sin fines de
lucro y hacer
atención de adultos mayores albergues
asilos fundaciones etcétera entonces
ellos dicen somos personas serias
honestas y de buenas costumbres y pues
da su correo electrónico es muy bien
excelente tengo acá sobre eres mexicano
vives en canadá y quieres votar en las
presidenciales de 2018 y escribe
veronica y dice vamos de vacaciones a
canadá estaremos en quebec donde podemos
votar aquí creo que ya está confundido y
si ma ella vive en méxico viene de
vacaciones a canadá acá no puede votar
tiene que ser ciudadana canadiense y
votar en los consulados mexicanos pero
ella no está en egipto en el consulado
mexicano hay que estar inscrito pero
ella viene de méxico entonces no puede
votar acá yo no sé cómo es la ley en
méxico en argentina si estás más de 500
kilómetros estás exentos pero tenés que
justificar exacto ir a la policía del
lugar donde estés para que certifiquen
que estuviste sí sí
horas de todas maneras le aconsejamos a
veronica que venga acá a un consulado
mexicano en lugares y que si tiene que
hacer un trámite para demostrar que
estuvo acá o puede votar en fin pero ir
a un consulado de donde se encuentra que
ya tienen voto anticipado está probable
es probable tal vez es tal vez sí aquí
tengo otro mensaje sobre la noticia a
gustavo petro es el favorito si las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia y
álex nos dice claramente se lee que se
ve se tiene tinte liberal los mismos que
sabotearon la reelección en harper
tienen en su redacción afectos a la
candidatura de gustavo petro un ex
guerrillero que tiene cuentas pendientes
con la justicia además vive como
millonario y predica la lucha por la
equidad este es el mensaje de álex que
nos envía sobre gustavo petro favorito
hacia las elecciones en colombia que
tiene cuentas pendientes con la justicia
dudo mucho
podría ser candidato de ninguna manera
en colombia de todas maneras respetamos
la opinión de este oyente
y emilio antonio garcía varas con
respecto al tema las opciones de una
médica latinoamericana que quiere
ejercer en montreal él dice en primer
lugar agradecer a dios y muchas
felicitaciones qué orgullo para tus
padres para nuestro país perú y para
esta persona que te escribe con mucho
cariño y orgullo de ser mi querida
sobrina hoy mañana y siempre espero en
algún momento darte un abrazo grande y
fuerte personalmente quien te escribe es
antonio garcía varas pareja de tu
diabetes muchas bendiciones no tengo
palabras cómo expresar mi felicidad
antonio garcía que saluda a su sobrina
que es una médica latinoamericana que
quiere ejercer aquí en montreal estamos
como la como esas radios antiguas en que
no te preocupes que ya llaman del
cordero cocido que va a llegar hasta acá
[Música]
en el servicio de radio nacional san
luís y nosotros los domingos de 6 a 10
eran mensajes para la gente del campo
estoy hablando hace 15 20 años atrás no
hace la función social muy importante la
hija que el lunes lo pasa a buscar en
tal puesto tal ley que le llegan
encomienda que por favor esté preparado
porque deba pedir no había teléfonos
celulares tampoco esa campo mucho menos
la vía no había otra manera muy bien
rufo buenas yo con nueve kilos
[Risas]
bueno estoy pensando en navidad
este mensaje nos manda el sobre el tema
eres mexicano vives en canadá y quieres
votar a la presidencial del 2018 te
decimos como mendoza escribe votar es
respetar nuestra constitución y eso
seguramente respetará nuestro futuro
presidente recordar que la constitución
es el fruto de la revolución de 1910
donde a muchos les costó su vida para
lograrlo y ahora tener escuelas públicas
carreteras libertad y algo que no
debemos olvidar parcelas donde vivir y
sembrar y darle al trabajador el justo
salario que merece y su pensión que al
final lo iba a necesitar etcétera esto
no nos debe hacer pensar que por quién
debo votar debe tener inteligencia
experiencia para servir a nivel nacional
qué importante es conocer su vida y su
ejemplo y esto en buena parte nos
garantiza que seguir adelante y no habrá
retroceso por el bien de cada mexicano
de mendoza tengo acá un mensaje sobre el
verano se anuncia caluroso en canadá con
sequías e incendios
y nuestro amigo desde méjico él nos dice
amigos no les doy el pésame acá en
méxico estamos pasando por una onda de
calor insoportable hemos tenido hasta 37
grados centígrados en los últimos días
me parecen muy altas como ustedes dicen
y también los meteorólogos esto es causa
del cambio climático muchos saludos a
todos hayan montreal pablo tienes
mensajes si yo tengo acá otro mensaje de
rodrigo vega gamma-ray cuervos con
respecto a la segunda vuelta electoral
en colombia
él dice deseo estar equivocado en mis
predicciones pero veo muy reñida la
llegada al poder por parte de duque en
todo caso lo cierto es que la mayoría de
personas de bien y de principios morales
y religiosos vemos en duke la
alternativa para detener la creciente
descomposición social que afecta nuestra
es el mensaje de rodrigo vega más
recuerdo con respecto a las elecciones
de colombia yo aquí tengo dos saludos
análisis más él dice salud de vis no
deben saber bien mi gran amiga al iess
marcel que ya está en francia
maravilloso en sobres en la provenza
francesa saludos a lis y cintia caso nos
dice hola soy mexicana me llegaron mis
boletas para votar con dirección
equivocada aquí hay un dato o sea la
persona que viene vacaciones tiene que
tener las boletas para aclarar para
votar en este caso a 100 que le llegaron
con dirección equivocada en la guía
prepagada y es muy triste porque ahora
debo dice denuncia baste que se va a
renunciar y ya no podré votar así que
qué pena y lamentablemente o si no
también siente pena por no poder hacerlo
y benicia barrios carey desde
barranquilla colombiano saluda está
escuchando una norma luna
y pues aquí está ahora tengo un saludo
también de carlos tapia que está
mirándonos desde chile saludos desde
chile
muy bien
rufo quiere decirle que él nos escribe
sobre el caso de bonn en ecuador por
segunda vez ante las cortes canadienses
y vemos que hay que crear hace un
magnífico esfuerzo para escribirnos en
español voy a leer tal como está escrito
deseo que canadá de la razón al
ecuatoriano con el fin de enganchar el
proceso de proteger y de continuar con
rosas de proteger a los humanos derechos
los derechos humanos ante las grandes
compañías sin conciencia social si las
compañías tienen derechos también tienen
deberes responsabilidades y obligaciones
dice si le clear yo aquí tengo un último
un último mensaje y es el español y los
adultos mayores en canadá es un formato
largo un formato que estamos
experimentando en radio canadá este fin
de semana salen los nuevos sale el de
pablo y en las otras cuatro lenguas de
radical internacional también va a salir
publicado aquellos que lean más de una
lengua pueden consultarlos en este caso
juan carlos sobre el españoles o adultos
mayores en canadá dice muy interesante
reportaje muchas gracias
también sorprendido de que la lengua
española se le conoce desde tan son
tantos años muy bien acá tengo sobre el
tema canadá promete protección total a
las personas transexuales escribe marley
da y dice felicitaciones por ser un país
con total claridad en cuanto a su forma
de pensar de actuar y de sentir en el
cual cada ser humano debe sentirse libre
y de expresar lo que siente siempre con
respeto en mi país venezuela a pesar de
sus leyes
yo como bisexual no podemos contar con
ese privilegio ya que existe total
discriminación y homofobia y total
rechazo a eso el gobierno y que apoya
eso pero no es así porque ni siquiera
existen matrimonios igualitarios en el
cual habla de un país libre y
democrático pero no es así esto es lo
que nos escribe más leyda me hace
acordar un poco al mundial justamente de
rusia que se lleva a cabo en rusia digo
el mundial de fútbol y donde ya amnistía
internacional le emitió un comunicado
dirigido expresamente al presidente
putin
diciéndole de que tiene que hacer una
declaración de que no van a perseguir a
la gente que sé que no es heterosexual
es decir sabemos que rusia tiene esa
política dice que no existen personas ni
homosexuales ni transexuales ni na
solamente las heterosexuales y hay
persecución en rusia entonces ese era el
mensaje de amnistía internacional
incluso brasil lanzó ya también publicó
un comunicado alertando a los brasileños
que van a brasil de no llevar a los most
rusia perdón gracias rufo a rusia de no
hacer demostraciones públicas porque
corre el riesgo y un vídeo que llenar tú
demostraste que ese es un vídeo en
realidad es un vídeo promocional de un
canal de televisión argentino que se
sacó de las pantallas porque justamente
una crítica muy fuerte con respecto a
eso porque hablaba de digamos asia
contó de no un racconto de lo que el
argentino vive como el fútbol y tiene
mucho contacto ante hombres
yo lo vi yo no pude terminar de verlo me
resultó totalmente homofóbico porque en
realidad era justamente tomándole el
pelo putin que salía y yo creo que había
algo más que tomarle el pelo a putin yo
lo que sentí cuando vi ese vídeo y no
pude terminarlo era machista y
homofóbico esto es lo que yo lo entendí
en realidad como un como una tomada de
pelo y eso fue lo que pasó en realidad
por eso lo sacaron de ondas porque la
embajada de rusia en argentina pidió que
fuera sacado de las mondas porque era
respetuoso para con la figura
presidencial para la política palestina
lo estuvimos viendo todos los dos y cada
uno en realidad la política está allá
adentro jorge sampaoli
el director técnico argentina no quería
cual ese partido de antemano pero no por
una cuestión política sino porque era
había que viajar justo antes de viajar a
rusia era bastante complejo él había
hecho que no y sin embargo la afa por
intermedio del gobierno argentino habían
dispuesto que se jugara y finalmente
bueno pasó lo que pasó se tuvo que
suspender amenazas los palestinos los
israelíes de uno contra otro otro contra
uno amenazas y de vuelta
llamando por teléfono y indicaron
finalmente que lo que si argentina no
venía era un acto terrorista claro bueno
a mí lo que me parece mal de esta
historia es que la afa no devuelve el
dinero
eran como tres millones de dólares que
le pagaban a la afa para que jugara el
equipo de la empresa ahora dice que no
le no le quiero devolver pronto se van a
programar otro partido para fin de año
en sus intereses la política digo el
fútbol no escapa el deporte no escapa en
los partidos de esos partidos amistosos
tan cerca ya de la fecha del mundial
árboles
por las lesiones que le pasó al racing y
que se lesionó en fin ese es el temor y
por eso quizás a sampaoli no quería que
se jugará ese partido no igual que con
el viaje o sea porque había que viajar
de barcelona hasta israel para después
viajar desde ahí hasta barcelona nuevo
para viajar de nuevo hacia rusia o sea
era bastante complejo para la cuestión
del corporal de los juzgan caía también
un poquito mal de que se hiciera pues un
viaje en un partido digo con la
selección argentina en jerusalén
antes se habían hecho era la costumbre
argentina va a israel cuando son los
mundiales va y juega y sólo hacían pero
no en jerusalén entonces eso era como un
poco que llamaba la atención aquí bueno
javi m dice saludos desde ecuador
ecuador
gonzález y antonio al gol o antonio algo
lo que dice
y efectivamente porque dice sadous a 2
supongo que se salutaciones a los
comunicadores de radio cara
internacional escuchando desde brasil
aquí en bahía
se acordará un espectáculo grabado en
argentina de vinicius de moraes con
vinicius de moraes y toquinho y maria
creuza famoso disco bueno muchos maridos
son bueno vamos a ver qué temas
destacaron entonces durante la semana
pablo bosch nos hablas de algo bastante
interesante el aumento de la esperanza
de vida entre los canadienses y el
envejecimiento también de la población y
hay algo que destacar aquí no es decir
se está alargando la vida pero sí parece
ser que no están buenas noticias como
parece dientes a primera vista bueno
porque al parecer la esperanza de vida
de los canadienses aumentó
de 10 años en las últimas dos décadas
pero hay algunos especialistas que dicen
que esta no es una buena noticia como
tal porque digamos que las personas
organizan su retiro en función de la
fecha de su jubilación entonces él dice
que si la persona acá y más o menos en
casi todos los lugares del mundo entre
comillas diría yo se jubila a los 65
años entonces ahora es aumentar la
esperanza de vida aunque aumente la
esperanza de vida de 10 años así que
todos los cálculos que se han hecho para
hacer los ahorros y para la jubilación
estén falsos porque te están agregando
10 años más que no había contado en los
cálculos antes de la esperanza que tiene
su jubilación pero se va a la inflación
el costo de la vida y cada vez tienen
menos dinero entonces esos 10 años
cuidar las monedas y además de eso
aparte de la parte económica que es muy
importante también lo que dice este
especialista que es
que es ya que antes que profesores de la
escuela de altos estudios comerciales de
la universidad de montreal él dice que
finalmente no es tan buena noticia
tampoco porque esos diez años los
últimos diez años no son los mejores en
términos de salud la luz mucha gente a
esa edad está está con problemas de
salud y no son los mejores años entonces
lo cual para esas personas no no es el
momento lo mejor que le puede suceder
entonces pues que proponen bueno no sé
qué hacer para tener células nuevas
yo creo que leonardo va a agregar algo
es el respecto pero otro de los
problemas que
suscita este tema de los 10 años de
esperanza de vida es que para para venir
a buscar esos ahorros que están faltando
a causa de esos 10 años lo que hace la
gente es que está haciendo lo que ellos
llaman una hipoteca invertida hace es
decir que llega se arreglan con los
bancos como les está faltando liquidez
entonces se arreglan con los bancos para
que los bancos le envíen mensualmente un
monto de dinero que van deducían volando
se van para costa tecka y al final del
día al final
el banco recupera la casa y le entrega
el excedente a los herederos en otras
palabras las herencias los que estaban
pensando en tener una herencia pues
tienen que verificar el tejido porque
con este nuevo con estos 10 años de
expectativa de vida no pueden mantener
la herencia que esperaba leonardo boff
tiene se presenta células solas
eres flexibles que alimentan
dispositivos electrónicos a nivel
industrial o la la que título así de
traducir es un proyecto en realidad que
está siendo compartido entre
investigadores de montreal y finlandia o
sea el canadá y finlandia que están
analizando cuáles son los desafíos para
la producción y bueno finalmente la
comercialización a gran escala desde
esta tecnología experimental que son
pequeñas células flexibles que van
dentro de los teléfonos para que el
teléfono se puede mandarle al teléfono y
todo lo que sea transportable puede ser
cargado gracias a la energía solar
entonces plantean
elementos raros para poder lograr que
esa flexibilidad se produzca que se
pueda hacer que sea viable para la
fabricación y que tenga mucha
durabilidad la mentalidad también se
plantea la durabilidad de los teléfonos
en este caso y por supuesto uno de los
pensamientos más interesantes es la
cuestión del bajo impacto ambiental
entonces es la universidad de montreal
con un país de euros y una universidad
finlandesa finlandesa bueno yo les
presento el tema que es de dos
instituciones canadienses que ofrecen
becas a mujeres de américa latina y esto
para aprender inglés se trata de la
academia de lenguas de canadá y l'aquila
xian la alianza de negocios hispano
canadiense que ofrecen becas son 10
becas la iniciativa tiene por objetivo
dar una mano profesionalmente hablando a
mujeres de habla hispana pues es es muy
interesante este proyecto ya se hizo una
primera expresa experiencia con la
universidad ryerson en toronto y que
funcionó muy bien se dieron 12 becas
las becas serán para el hijos
latinoamericanos de canadá entonces lo
que decía el entrevistado es que por
primera vez
la mitad de esos chicos que obtuvieron
las becas era la primera generación que
iba a la universidad de inmigrantes
latinoamericanos esta vez está dirigido
a américa latina y a mujeres
específicamente entonces los que estén
interesados pues van al sitio web
nuestro y ahí está toda la información
para los que quieran presentarse para
obtener esas becas y rufo vos hiciste un
justamente un reportaje sobre como
voluntarios se preparó para estas
elecciones pusiste todo en contexto pues
básicamente hablamos ya una buena parte
del impacto del programa y lo que se
destaca el de acabes justamente hasta
ayer los los cálculos indicaban que
tanto los nuevos demócratas con su
candidata a presidente
andrew a harvard principal del cne o
demócrata estaba codo a codo con
observan observadores y pues el discurso
digamos era que bueno
de que había la publicidad de que
también fuera gobierno
y hablaba justamente con algunos algunos
alguna gente en ontario y me decían que
lo que pasó es que
ocurrió lo que ocurre a menudo es que tú
en tu espacio la gente piensa la calle
hay anuncios a favor de andy y tus
amigos están todos príncipe y eso da
como una falsa percepción de la realidad
que no es necesariamente que primó
solamente eso y lo que hay que destacar
es que también fue por primera vez el
partido verde logró una diputación con
un match trainer es una es una primera
primera vez que este partido llega y
notará la legislatura desde esa
provincia interesante y seguramente en
el partido verde este diputado va a ver
ven muchas cosas van a hacer alianza
también con él en pd no y también está
la diferencia generacional porque como
decíamos al principio en la última vez
que hubo un gobierno conservador en
ontario fue hace 15 años y la figura a
la cabeza de ese gobierno era mike
harris también
me acuerdo de las medidas antipopulares
a nivel económico pues eran neoliberales
mafiosa
acuerdo y otro aspecto de esta victoria
de los conservadores es el trabajo de
los cerebros grises detrás de detrás de
esta campaña de oxford porque finalmente
un poco como lo que pasó contra la crom
que programa entra pero detrás hay hay
mucha gente muchos interista mulroney
está todos los cuadros políticos del
además ron y fue elegida también a
notarios ya se perfila para mí imagino
una ministerio si saluditos daniel
camporini saludos de un colectivo en
buenos aires la tecnología y avergonzar
en un garay que no se escuche su taxi
hasta montreal amigos darse y desde
guadalajara méjico y rafael bandera para
chico dice invitando a nuestros
compatriotas a votar para erradicar la
corrupción de colombia con un solo trazo
el 17 todos los bandidos en un solo
grupo
un saludo al panel saludos para ti
también
entonces esto pues aquí nos vamos ya no
nos queda más tiempo ha sido un placer
entonces amigos oyentes y que y que nos
están vídeos como dices pablo bosch
escucha viento pues muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros por haber
participado en el programa enviándonos
los mensajes dándonos su opinión será
pues entonces hasta el próximo viernes
chau adiós adiós
nos vamos ya no nos queda más tiempo ha
sido un placer entonces amigos oyentes y
que y que nos están vídeo como dices
pablo bosch escucha viento pues
muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros por haber participado en el
programa enviándonos los mensajes
dándonos su opinión será pues entonces
hasta el próximo viernes ya dios adiós